hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
visualize
aso micro rna or sirna detections with
spatial resolution
using the new micro rna scope assay
i'm alexis cross of labyrinth and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths
and sponsored by advanced cell
diagnostics a biotechne brand
for more information about our sponsor
please visit their website at acdbio.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click on the send button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
ask a question box
located on the far left of your i'd like
to now introduce our presenters
hallie pimentel product manager advanced
cell diagnostics and miguel mata
scientists at advanced cell diagnostics
for a complete biography on our
presenters
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
kelly you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone thank you for joining our
webinar my name is helly pimentel
and i'm a product manager at event cell
diagnostics abbreviated as acd
acd is a division of biotechnic
corporation
my colleague miguel mata a scientist
from the r d department will be
co-hosting with me today
for today's webinar we're delighted to
introduce you to acd's newest product
offering
called the micrornascope assay
specifically designed for the detection
of small non-coding rnas
such as micrornas and short therapeutic
oligos
such as small interfering rnas and
antisense oligos
on the agenda for today we'll first
introduce you to acd's product portfolio
for the use of a wide range of
applications then we'll switch gear and
introduce you to the newest microniscope
assay
to detect smaller rnas after that
my colleague miguel will present on the
common applications that necessitate the
use of the microscope assay
along with some beautiful data to share
with you additionally
we'll look at the asset controls and
provide our staining scoring
recommendations
towards the end we'll talk about the
product offering
as well as in-house asset services that
are available for your research
finally we'll summarize our presentation
and address some of your questions
to begin i would like to first talk
about the importance of single cell
transcriptomics
with spatial analysis
previous attempts at detecting rnas have
rely heavily on traditional bulk genomic
analysis tools
such as qpcr or microarray although
these methods deliver bulk expression
levels
they do not provide detailed spatial
information nor gene expression at
subcellular level
similarly single cell sequencing methods
could offer a single cell resolution
but still lack the important spatial
resolution that researchers need to
understand gene localization
so that brings us to acv technology
where our advanced insights
rehabilitation technology
enable signal cell facial analysis of
any gene
from any species allowing analysis of
where exactly every single molecule is
located
relative to every other molecule in the
tissue sample
these spatial and single cell
information is important for
understanding pathological relevance of
transcript tones
acd's core technology is the rna scope
technology
rna scope is an ideal spatial analysis
solution to interrogate complex tissues
it is a highly specific and sensitive
method to detect rna biomarkers in cells
and tissues with morphological context
at the single cell resolution
the rna scope technology consists of
three parts a unique target probe that
acb designs
against your sequence of interest a
signal amplification system
that generates a high signal to noise
ratio and lastly
visualization of single rna molecules of
dots
for quantitative analysis fiat allows
for the spatial mapping of
mrnas long non-coding rna
white variants highly homologous
sequences
permutations all the way to small rna
such as micrornas and srna
and cells and intact tissues all which
can be visualized with either
fluorescence
or chromogenic labels in addition
the aussie can be performed on a variety
variety of sample types
including fft tissue fresh poses or
fixed frozen tissues
and culture cells
next focusing on the core rna scope
technology workflow
the rna scope workflow is similar to
immunohistochemistry
so researchers who are familiar with the
tissue-based protein aspase
find required intuitive to adopt this
workflow
first we start with properly
permeabilized cells or tissue
with acd's pretreatment reagents then we
hybridize the unique probe
acv design to the target rnav interest
next with addition of the proprietary
amplification system
in the form of detection reagent which
allows the visualization of a single rna
molecule
in the form of dots and enables us to
quantify the level of gene expression
indirectly
the combination of probe design strategy
and the amplification system
allows for a high signal to noise
detection of the target rna
our products cater to each of these
steps providing ready-to-use reagents in
most cases to design a specific pro for
your target of interest
acd request is used to provide us either
a session number information
or the exact sequence of the target you
can even indicate your region of
interest
for targeting with start or stop
position
our bioinformatics scientists channel
this information
through the proprietary acd alignment
algorithm
to select optimum sequences to ensure
target specificity
and uniformity of oligohybridization in
the assay
our algorithm evaluates the sequence
composition of each algo in the pool
to ensure no cross habitation with
non-target ironing
under stranger and irony skill
conditions
next acd can design probes for virtually
any species
and have done so in over 200 species
covering most applications
that are highlighted on our website for
example the majority of our probes are
designed in human
and mouth on our website you will be
able to find the applications area
to demonstrate how these probes are used
in the most common applications
including infectious diseases cancer
neuroscience and gene therapy
we've also added support for signaling
pathways such as winds or jack steps
and indicated the probes we have
available within that pathway
in this slide we're looking at the three
unique aspects that acd
offers to detect any rna with spatial
mapping at single cell resolution
first on the left rna scope is designed
to detect
any mrnas or non-coding rnas that are
greater than 300 nucleotides in length
rna scope probes are designed in about
20 zz pro pairs
and the athletes are available in either
chromogenic or fluorescence detection
modalities
for up to 12 targets simultaneously in a
single slide
on the other hand the basic platform
listed here in the middle
uses probes that are designed in one to
three zv pro pairs
to specifically support the short target
detection of spice variants
highly homologous sequences permutations
or short targets
that are 50 to 300 nucleotides the base
scope assay can detect up to two targets
with the chromogenic assays
last but not least acd offers the newest
micrornas scope technology
to detect even the smaller rnas and
oligos such as micrornas
and defense oligos small interfering
rnas or other sequences
in the range of 17 to 50 nucleotides
this new aspect is currently available
as a chromogenic singleplex assay
now this slide summarizes all the assay
products that are currently available
from acd
we have chromogenic single plus brown or
red assays
and duquest assays on both the manual
and automated platforms
the multiplex fluorescence allows for
the detection of up to four targets
simultaneously
in a single tissue section the major
difference between the two fluorescent
acetate
is that the v2 assay uses fluorophores
from aquatic biosciences with signal
visualization and provides a high signal
to noise ratio
whereas the fluorescent multiplex assay
is an all-in-one kit
the v2 flow resonator is also available
on the leica automation platform
for higher plastic we have the rna scope
hypoplex assay
which enables the detection of up to 12
targets simultaneously
in a single tissue section currently the
hi-flex assay is available in the manual
format only
if your target of interest is shorter
than 300 nucleotides and studying spice
variants or point mutations
then the base cup acids will be the
right choice for you currently
the basic singleplex assay is available
on all platforms
while the duplex assay is available on
the manual platform
finally expanding our product portfolio
not only do we have athletes to detect
mrna
non-coding rnas short targets life
variants and permutations
but we now have the microarray scope
assay for the detection of microrna
small interfering rnas antisense oligos
or other smaller rnas as low as 17
nucleotides in length
as of today we have over 26 000 unique
target probes in our catalog
custom probes can also be designed
against any target from any species
in as little as two
for the remaining webinar we'll bring
our focus to acd's newest micrornas
scope process
overall the micronoscope assay is a
robust in situ hybridization assay
enabling highly sensitive and specific
detection of small non-coding rnas
such as micrornas short oligals such as
asos
and sirnas and tissues with spatial and
morphological context
a single cell resolution in addition to
these key applications that i just
mentioned the assay will also enable the
detection of
any smaller rnas that are 17 to 50
nucleotides in length
some popular targets include trnas and
pvrna
key research area for these top targets
include cancer research
infectious diseases neuroscience and
therapeutic target validations
additionally this new assay leverages
acv's core amplification system
and probe design capability to enable
the detection of rna molecules at single
cell resolution
while improving high signal to noise
detection of smaller rnas
with ease of data interpretation to
enable further insights into your
research
the microorganism assay is also
compatible with immunohistochemistry or
immunofluorescence of phase allowing the
detection of these small rnas
and proteins simultaneously on the same
tissue fly
next what are the specifics of the
microscope prototype
that makes the assay highly specific and
sensitive
the microarray skill probe design is a
brand new design strategy
for leveraging acv's core rna scope
technology
that the design algorithm screens the
whole transcriptome
to avoid any cross hybridization due to
the extremely short sequences of these
targets
sometimes cross habitation is
unavoidable
so in the cases of potential cross
hybridization
this information will be slowly
disclosed to our users for evaluation
however i would like to mention that the
majority of these cross detection
targets
are endogenous transcripts so we highly
recommend our users
to always include a negative control as
the baseline to interpret the data
for micrornas with cross detection we
recommend the use of a non-negative
control sample for the microrna target
on the other hand if your targets are
asos or sir names
we always recommend in your studies to
include a mock or untreated sample
for your data interpretation
in addition to the new probe design
strategy we also improve the probe
hybridization buffer
to deliver optimal acid performance
together with this condition
the microscope assay offers superior
sensitivity and specificity without the
need to further optimize the target pro
hybridization conditions
for the microorganiscope assay we also
offer a universal scramble sequence
probe as the negative control probe
to evaluate specificity of the assay
additionally
you could also request a specific
scramble sequence to be designed against
your smaller rna
as i just mentioned one of the key
features of the micro
iron scope assay is the probe design
the oligonucleotide target-specific
probes are designed using an
informatics algorithm that selects
sequences to specifically bind to the
target sequence
and not cross hybridized with any other
sequences
the bottom of the probe design
complements and hybridizes
to the target transcripts whereas the
top of the probe is the base for the
amplification structure
upon which a pre-amplifier can bind and
the amplification tree can then be built
once the pre-amplifiers are hybridized
to the target probe
multiple amplifiers are then added to
the pre-amplifiers
each amplifier can then further find
multiple label probes
sequentially hybridizing to assemble a
branching complex
at each probe design pro-binding site
label roles contain a chromogenic enzyme
that generates a visible signal
after chromogenic reaction in this case
with fast red
that is detectable under a standard rice
cell microscope
its entire amplification system allows
for highly sensitive and specific
visualization of target rnas
as pentaig dots
next we'll focus on the overview of the
microarranged scope acid workflow
the new micrornas scope acid workflow is
very similar to only
single plastic workflow for those of you
who are familiar with technology
first the cells or tissues that are
bound to a slight is permeabilized
using hdd's ready to use pretreatment
reagents
the new assay supports a variety of
sample types including ffte
fresh and fixed frozen and culture cells
then the smaller
rna target probes are hybridized to the
target rna
currently the microarranged subacade
allows for a single rna target detection
the pro hybridization step is universal
across all targets
meaning further probe optimization is
not required
after probe hybridization the target
probes will be hybridized with acd's
modified branch signal amplification
tree
consisting of amplifiers and labor
probes to provide high sensitivity
and specificity after the colors have
been developed
the small rna molecule signal can be
seen as red chromogenic
deposits using brazil microscopy i'd
also like to mention that the
fastback chromogen can also fluoresce
similar to the ato 550 dye
under a fluorescence microscope
these slides can then also be scanned
for further qualitative or quantitative
analysis
the entire singleplex asset workflow can
be done either manually or fully
automated using the leica
systems
switching gear as i mentioned in a
previous slide that the microscope assay
is compatible with multiple tissue types
on this slide we're demonstrating robust
athlete performance in various species
of formula
fixed paraffin embedded tissue samples
for example
demonstrated here microrna 124 3p
is detected in the mouth rest and human
brain tissue
with abundant signals detected to
demonstrate specificity
a known microrna 124 negative tissue
such as the mouse liver
is also stained with the microrna 124
probe as you can see here
the negative tissue shows no background
detection of the microrna 124 target
additionally the microscope assay
demonstrates similar detection
robustness with fresh pros and tissue
samples
demonstrated here in the left column
microrna124 is staying in the thresholds
and mouse brain tissue
with abundant signals similar to what we
just saw with the ffpe tissues
again the scramble probe is used as the
negative control to demonstrate acid
specificity
here showing no background was detected
on the right column
is another example of thresholds and
tissue but with microrna 122
stain in the mouse liver showing robust
detection of the target
and no background was detected with
descramble negative control
on the other hand if you are working
with culture at herring cells
the microscope assay also performs
extremely well as demonstrated in this
slide
with microrna 205 stained in a431 skin
cells
beyond they successfully detected the
abundant michelin
205 signals in the skin cells and again
the scramble probe was used as a
negative control
overall the micro microscope is a highly
robust assay that can work with any of
your sample types
so why choose acd's microscope assay
the microline scope assay offers many
benefits for your research
first of all the assay enables highly
specific and sensitive detection of your
smaller rna targets
as single cell resolution while
preserving spatial and morphological
contexts
additionally diabetes compatible with
multiple sample types
including ffp tissues fixed and fresh
frozen tissue
and cultured cells and then the benefit
of the microscope assay
is that it does not require an rna free
environment
like other typical athletes furthermore
the assay reagents also offer in
ready-to-use formats for ease of use
on top of that ac offers a one-on-one
scientific consultation
our expert technical support scientists
to ensure that you have a successful run
of the assay
in addition the microscope assay is
compatible with
xc staining enabling code detection of
rna
and protein in a single tissue slide
last but not least the micro and scope
assay uses universal acid conditions
where minimum optimizations are required
for a successful detection of your
target
prior to commercialization of the
product we have had many successful
customer stories
using the my current scope assay through
our in-house formal assay services team
for example one of our customers had
used the micronscope assay
to detect their si rnas and provided us
with an extremely valuable feedback
stating that the assad is incredibly
specific
and that the results are very easy to
understand
the acd pharmacy services team had
generated impeccable tissue staining for
their srna therapeutic research and
development
another successful customer who had used
micronuscoping
to detect their says that they use
acd's assay to detect both the rna and
short oligos
in serial tissue section which generates
signals that are both evident and
specific
and with that i'll hand it over to my
colleague miguel mata to provide you
with detailed presentation on how the
microscope could help with your research
application
thank you haley that was a great
introduction on the microscope platform
and as you mentioned now we'll go into
more detail related to the key
applications of this new ish assay
that we recently launched a couple of
weeks ago so
the key targets for this technology and
i will
describe a few of them a few examples of
this uh include the detection of this
single cell at the single cell
resolution of this uh small non-coding
regulatory rnas
that fall between the 15 to 17 sorry to
15 nucleotides
in range the short rna nucleotides
oligonical types include anti-semitism
nucleotides or asos
small interfering rna rna
or small hairpin rnas or shrnas
and these are the synthetically uh
designed oligonucleotides
and this particular oligonecotypes can
target specific disease
related transcripts and by doing so
they can transcriptionally down regulate
these targets that
reduce eventually the bioavailable
levels of a particular protein of
interest
and in the past few years the small rnas
have actually gained
a lot of interest as potential
therapeutic agents in a number of
diseases next is micrornas and these are
also
small non-coding rnas and they function
uh in rna silencing
more specifically at the
post-transcriptional gene simulation
level
also pvrnase and these are a also
short rna species that are slightly
larger than micrornas between 26 to 34
nucleotides
and they have been um associated with
silencing transposable elements
within the germline and also in somatic
tissue they regulate
mrna expression at the level of the
post-transcriptional
stages so this are
the next the next application is uh
ish and institute hybridization are
immunofluorescence
now marketers micrornascope workflow is
fully compatible with
ihc or if
uh now this is extremely important
application if there is a need to
identify a particular cell type of
interest
or even to determine the levels of a
particular protein
whose transcript was originally targeted
by one of the aforementioned
regulatory small rna now using micro and
scope you can specifically
identify any of this subtypes of small
rnas
and then using ihc you can identify
a particular cell type of interest
now these are all the key research areas
where my current scope
has made an enormous impact
first is basic science this is in terms
of
neuroscience stem cell and developmental
biology research
next is in terms of infectious diseases
in particular
with a focus on viral infections um and
also
immunoregulation
next in terms of biopharma therapeutics
as i mentioned srnas and asos have
gained a lot of attract
attention as novel therapeutic agents
and we'll discuss a few of them
uh in the later parts of the of the
of the webinar today and also cancer and
clinical research
here we will discuss the role of
micrornas and
other regulatory rnas in terms of immuno
oncology
and tumor biology so let's move to our
first application
which is micrornas
and their role in different research
areas
so some of the research areas include
oncology neuroscience
and immunology so how is microrna
detection
relevant to oncology so micrornas
can actually alter the transcriptional
landscape within single cells
by targeting cli players or even
signaling pathways
and in this way those pathways may have
some function
in malignant transformation some
targeted
micrornas have actually been identified
as
oncomers or a microrna that has the
ability to promote malignant
transformation
there's also on the other hand a
different class of micrornas that
actually have tumor suppressor
characteristics
in addition numerous micrornas have also
been identified as potential biomarkers
for a number of malignancies
what about neuroscience how is microrna
detection relevant
as it turns out there are numerous
micrornas that have been identified to
be deregulated
in different neurological disorders and
many of this
studies have actually implicated
micrornas as potential biomarkers as
well for neurodegenerative diseases
so it will be important to identify
those key micrornas
in uh with the spatial and the
morphological context that
micrornascope provides also in
immunology um there's particular
importance in terms of infectious
diseases
uh it is known that micrornas regulate
immune activation
of different pathways that are related
to the immune system
so failing to turn this pathway on the
rock can actually have severe
consequences
next we will talk about specific
micrornas
in key areas so the first area is
oncology
so here this slide is showing uh a
number of microrna targets
uh that were of course detected using
the microscope assay
and that have been implicated in some
cancers here we're showing two different
cancers
uh head and neck cancer on the bottom
and cervical cancer on the top
now these micrornas have previously been
implicated in cancer initiation or
progression
and they do so by deregulating signaling
networks
as i mentioned previously that may lead
to malignant transformation
now the first microrna that we have here
is mere 205
5p uh they're most left
and this particular microrna is
interesting is one of the most popular
micrornas studied
in oncology because it's known to
promote tumor invasion
migration angiogenesis and it does so
in part by activating the akt signaling
pathway
next is mir of 215p and this is one of
the actually one of the earliest
identified cancer-promoting
micrornas or otherwise known as oncomers
and it has been shown that in several
oncology cases this particular microrna
in fact
activates the pa3 akt signaling pathway
and that also enhances oncogenic krs
activation
leading to tumor initiation and
progression
now the next two micrornas are very
interesting are very
interesting to us this is mir 155 5p
and mirror 2235p now this is our
immune cell enriched micrornas in
particular mir 155
is it's from a lymphoid origin
enriched microrna uh an example would be
t cells
and mir-223 is expressed primarily in
myeloid
cells um for example macro veggies and
neutrophils
and what we're seeing here is that those
two micrornas
together with the cells that where
they're expressed they're infiltrating
this two particular cancers here
so in fact these two micrornas can be
used as biomarkers to identify
these two different cell types ones that
are from lymphoid origin
and others that are from a myeloid
origin
and lastly we have a scramble stain
tissues
showing the specificity of this new acid
and of course showing no signal
whatsoever
next this is an example of microrna
detection coupled with ihc
looking at a particular t cell specific
marker which is cd3 now as i mentioned
before micrornascope assay is fully
compatible with immunohistochemistry
and if a researcher has previously
optimized
rna scope issue conditions they can be
easily transferred to this assay
now this is a very important technique
uh having both
uh the workflow for asian ihc because as
i mentioned previously
this enables the identification of
specific
cell types within a particular tissue of
interest
now here mir-223 3p is detected in
red and cd3 marker is staining
green as i mentioned t-cell marker
now this as i mentioned mir-223 is
a myeloid-specific microrna whereas cd3
is a lymphoid
marker so as expected we observe
detection of the two targets are
mutually exclusive
given that they're coming from two
different lineages
moving on to the next application is
neuroscience
and micrornas have actually been
implicated to play roles
from early early stages in development
all the way to adulthood
in this particular image we're actually
showing detection of a neural specific
microrna
near 124 3p and this is in
the mouse spring now this particular
micrornas expressed
in early development and continues to be
expressed at very high levels
throughout the animal adulthood
now amir 124 actually plays a crucial
role in supporting neuronal
differentiation
and one way in which it does this is by
targeting a
a particular mrna called ptbp
we're also showing here detection of mir
124 across
various species so we have the mouse
brain on the left
the red brain in the center human brain
to the right
and also we're not known here but we
have also looked at
other different species such as
non-human primates horse and even rabbit
tissues
in the mouths example we're actually
seeing a very strong staining of mir124
in the hippocampal region which is right
in the center of that particular image
also in the red brain we're seeing high
expression in the cerebellum
and in the human brain this particular
section
can be seen exclusively expressed
in the human tissue
now and to demonstrate the specificity
of this particular
probe and overall the micrornas scope
assay we're showing a negative tissue
known to lack expression of this
particular microrna which is a mouse
flavor
and this again shows the specificity of
the probe and the acid itself
moving out moving on to again
neuroscience but now
capturing other micrornas
uh so in the previous two slides we have
shown mir 124
and now here we're showing it in a uh
a higher magnification image
demonstrating the high level of
enrichment among
neuronal cells to its right it's let
7b5p
and this is a member of the
well-established left 7
family of ultra-conserved micrornas so
this particular microrna is actually
expressed across the mouse brain and
many other tissues
and it has previously been implicated in
central nervous pathology
tumor growth and also immune response
meteor 134 mere 138 through p it's right
next to it
and this particular micrornas shows a
very distinct expression pattern
in the purkinje cells within the
cerebellum
as can be seen in the higher
magnification image now this particular
microrna plays a role in cellular
differentiation
and maintenance and this also shows
a perfect example of the spatial
distribution morphological context
that is necessary to really understand
the biology behind
micrornas also we have mir1283p
and this is a microrna that was detected
in cortical region of the brain
previously has been shown to be
implicated in control of neurogenesis
and synaptogenesis
and also in your hormonal migration and
outgrowth
again as a control to show the
specificity of the
probes and the assay we have a scramble
same tissue showing
negligible amount of signal
now moving on to developmental biology
and this is perhaps one of our favorite
images
this is in the showing the mouse
e15 e15.5 embryo sagittal section
at the top we have the brain or the head
of the animal
and on the bottom it's the uh the
embryo's body
now this particular slide again
highlights the
assay specificity compared to its
negative control on the right
and the exquisite spatial distribution
of mir-124
specifically in the central nervous
system also
it shows the assay's ability to retain
morphological context
which is really critical to really
understand the function of this
or any other microlearning
other micrornas that are also involved
in developmental biology
this particular microrna mir 145 5p
and this is a cartilage specific micro
name
again this slide shows e15.5 embryos
and three key areas we're highlighting
here first digits
on the far left second the cell mice in
the center
and the ear structure on the right now
mere 145p
is actually being detected at different
levels across these different tissue
structures
again this is necessary to understand
how
micrornas are regulating different
biological
signaling networks and mere 145p is
actually one of its main targets it's
fecal
tilt transferees or foot1 and this
particular
rna has been implicated in those
osteoarthritis
which is actually characterized by
corollas degradation and chondrocyte
injury
we also show here on the bottom scramble
stained tissues
showing no signal for this particular
tissues
our next example is a microrna
in development it's a mir-1825p and it's
being detected in the mouse eye
specifically in the retina now this
particular microrna
is uh was it's originally from
literature uh
expected to be expressed in the outer
nuclear layer of the retina
and this is the place where the cell
bodies of the photoreceptors
are housed for example the cones and the
rods
now here mirror 182 is shown
in the outer nuclear layer with very
little to no
expression in the inner nuclear layer or
the ganglion
cell layer which are the layers just
below the red chromogen
mir 182 has actually been shown to be
necessary to maintain adult cone
photoreceptor and visual function and in
fact in
mouse studies deletion of this
particular micro name
results in retinol dysfunction
next is the detection of the enriched
vascular smooth muscle cell microrna
near 145 5p now mirror 145 is actually a
regulator of
vsmcs and it does so by regulating the
proliferation
and migration by targeting two key
signaling pathways
smat in the tgf beta signaling cascades
now in this light we have actually
captured two different tissues
uh to show the specificity of this
particular probe we have the mouse lung
on the left
intestine in the center and the kidney
on the far right
as can be clearly observed there's this
particular micrornas quite abundant
but it's also very specific to the
smooth muscle cells
found in these different mouse tissues
next we're going to switch gears and
we're going to talk about a different
class
of small non-coding regulatory rnas and
these are the synthetic type
and how the microenescope assay can
address this particular application
this are the small interfering rnas or f
irons
and as mentioned they're synthetically
designed and they can target a
particular irony of interest
and in many cases those targets include
transcripts with a bearing expression
can lead
to a particular disease state now it has
been
uh it's been envisioned that in the next
few years
many srna therapeutics will be entering
the clinic to treat a number of diseases
so what are some of the key applications
uh where srnas are being
utilized first is an oncology and
srna therapeutics are mainly focusing on
targeting oncogenes
in a number of malignancies and in doing
so a modulating transcriptional
landscape
in an attempt to control tumor growth
next is neuroscience
and srnas are being evaluated as
promising tools for acute brain injury
treatment
as well as other neutral
neurodegenerative diseases
and finally in immunology field srnas
can actually target
genes that are involved in autoimmune
disorders and in this way hopefully slow
down disease progression
now market microorganiscope is actually
a perfect tool
to detect this particular srnas and to
evaluate uh numerous
parameters associated with s ironing
delivery within
our assay services team we've actually
looked into
different srna chemistries or
modifications and how these
modifications
impact biodistribution and also
looking into dosage studies as well as
stability of the srnas
in longitudinal studies
this is an example of a recent study
that was completed through our
assay services team and in this
particular example we have an srna
which we're going to call for the
purposes of today srna1
and a particular cohort of animals was
delivered to srna
a different animal cohort to the left
was administered saline
or is otherwise our negative control and
the far right tissue is showing an
animal cohort
which was delivered the srna number two
molecule
now this light captures the specificity
of the micronuscope assay
as only srna1 is being detected with the
srna number one probe
while there is no signal observed in
either the saline or in the
completely independent srna number two
molecule delivered to a different cohort
now again this slide shows the type of
actionable data that can be obtained
with the microscope assay
this data can drive new hypothesis or
questions that are related
to chemistry of psrna dosage how does
that
impact stability the biodistribution of
the cell rnas
and of course the impact on the target
of interest
moving on to the next synthetic
uh synthetic oligo where micronuscope
has made an
impact are antisense oligonucleotides or
asos
now this synthetic oligos are typically
single stranded
in nature and they're actually designed
to target genes of interest
a research area where asos are
continuing to being evaluated
is oncology and in oncology specifically
they're being synthetically designed to
target and block
oncogene expression in neuroscience they
have emerged as
important therapeutic strategies now
aso-based therapies are now
used to target genes that were actually
considered at one point and druggable
and many of these asos are actually
moving through the clinical trial
pipeline
and in some cases some asos have
actually already gained
fda approval for the treatment of
neuromuscular disorders
finally in terms of immunology synthetic
oligonucleotides can target
key immune regulators in a number of
diseases
including autoimmune disorders
to show you an example where micrornas
scope as a
specifically detective sir a target of
interest
we're showing here two different tissues
one
mouse cardiac muscle and the one on the
right mouse quad muscle
now different animals were administered
either a vehicle
or saline treated or they were
administered the aso of interest here
and this slide shows the specificity
of the micronuscope assay detecting the
aso
in the treated only animals whereas
vehicle shows
negligible amount of signal
finally our last application is
detection of
prna now these are by far considered the
largest class of
small non-coding rna molecules and as
mentioned previously they range between
26 to 30
26 to 30 um six nucleotides in length
faster than traditional
microarrangements
now prnas are involved in two key
research areas which include epigenetics
and oncology
in terms of epigenetics prnas are so
in their associated effector peewee
proteins
they're called the guardians of the
germline as they maintain genome
integrity and fertility
primarily by preventing dna elements
from moving through different
genomic regions in terms of oncology a
number of prnas
and their associated proteins have also
been shown to be abnormally expressed in
numerous cancer types however their
function and mechanism is still
very largely unknown
this is an example showing detection of
three germline specific
pvr names here we are in a 1
3 13 11 21 which are the first three
images
and the mouse testes are shown here and
as i mentioned
uh pvrnase play a role in transposon
surveillance mechanisms
now this based on literature these three
prnas have actually been isolated and
also validated
as kiwi protein interacting rna
using a number of different approaches
now pvrna
detection appears as very strong
perinuclear pontate
dots and specifically in the
spermatogonia which is
undifferentiated male germline cells
that eventually give rise to mature
spermatozoa
now this staining pattern is actually
similar to that published in
other literature reports at the negative
control as we have continued
uh showing we have a scramble probe
where there's little to no signal that
can be observed in this particular mouse
tissue moreover we actually
looked into other somatic tissues as i
mentioned
this prnas are germline specific so we
wanted to determine
specificity of this probes we're showing
here the mouse liver
a somatic tissue and we have
negligible levels of peewee detection
as expected again showing the
specificity
and the sensitivity of our micronuscope
and with that i'll let healthy continue
thank you miguel for the excellent
application demonstrations
in the next few slides i'll talk about a
recommended acid controls and scoring
guidelines
for the microscope assay
the microscope assay to detect smaller
rna will offer
universal positive and negative control
probes that will work for any species or
samples
for deposits control we recommend the
small nuclear usage probe which is known
to be expressed in most tissue samples
for example on the top row here shows
strong nuclear usage signal
observed in a variety of tissues
including human and mouse tissues
and hela and 3t3 cell pellets on the
other hand
a universal scramble probe is
recommended as the negative control
probe
to demonstrate assay specificity and to
be used for data interpretation against
your target
next we'll focus on the microscope
scoring recommendations
the microscopic data could be analyzed
with either
dummy quantification or a single cell
analysis with a software analysis tool
such as halo or other open source
software analysis tools
the semi quantum scoring criteria shown
here is specific for the microscope
assay
which provides guidelines for target
expression levels as counted by dots per
cell
if your target is highly expressed such
as with 20 dots or more per cell
then we recommend a score of 3 whereas
if your target is moderately expressed
with
11 to 20 dots per cell a score of 2 is
assigned
the lower target signal detected such as
2 to 10 dots per cell
a score of 1 is assigned lastly a score
of 0 is assigned if there are no
staining or less than 1 dot per cell
absurd
a note that we want to mention is that
due to the relatively small size of the
micrornas or asos or sioni targets
dependent dots seen under the microscope
may represent multiple copies
as a result we recommend our users to
interpret their data
by relative quantification meaning that
they should always use the negative
control as the baseline
for measuring the change in the target
probe expression
next i'll go over the microscope
products that are available
as mentioned previously the
microarranged scuba assay is offered in
both the manual
and leica formats each assay with
universal control probes that are
species independent
but are platform specific so be sure to
request the current catalog
number for the active format that you
prefer
for the manual update we have the hd
reagent kit
that includes all the pre-treatment
reagents along with the detection
reagents needed for the assay
in addition we also offer two
introduction packs for the most popular
species samples
such as human and mouse for your
convenience
where the packs include the pre-trimming
reagents detection reagents
control cell pallets mounting medium and
a hydrophobic barrier pen that are
necessary to complete the entire assay
on the other hand for leica users we
have the
ls reagent kit where include the
pre-treatment reagents
wash buffer and detection reagents the
microorganisms go target probes are
designed in the s1 channels that are
specific for this assay
and cannot be interchangeably used with
the other aspects such as omniscope or
base scope
we're very delighted to also share with
you that we have a rich list of micron
scope probes
pre-designed as catalog probes so you
can request them immediately
feel free to reach out to your local
account manager or our support team for
the list of pros available
custom design requests we request you to
submit your target through the
acv's new quote request web document on
our web page
that's listed on this slide in addition
to products we also offer in-house asset
services
for those of you who would like to send
in your sample
we understand the challenges that many
of us are facing during the pandemic
however research must go on and that's
why our services team are here to assist
you
with moving your research forward our
pharmacy services are fully operational
and could help you advance your research
in the detection of micrornas
asos or sinoit or sir nays if you'd like
to send in your samples and prefer the
assays to be validated by acd
by carnoscope assay experts our services
team ensures all due care is taken with
examples
and that the athlete development and
analysis are conducted with highest
efficiency
with minimum time our family asset
services has recently received awards
from the pharma
tech outlook for being one of the top 10
cros
of 2019 and 2020 consecutively
in addition to pharmacy services we also
offer academic asset services
for those of you who are working in the
institution the benefits of having acd
validate your target of interest in your
samples
include saving resources with your pilot
study before setting up for a larger
scale in your own lab
and receiving your results in a quick
turnaround for your grant application
or paper submissions for further
information
please contact our support team with the
email address listed here
to summarize today's topic apd's new
microscope assay is the robust rna in
situ hybridization assay
enabling the detection of smaller rnas
in tissue with spatial and morphological
contexts
as single cell resolution key
applications
of acd's meal assay include asos
micrornas srnas
or other short rna sequences that are 17
to 15 nucleotides
the new assay is a single-player
chromogenic threat assay
that is compatible with manual platform
or the fully automated leica platform
the microline scope assay is also
compatible with ihd
or if staining for the visualization of
rna and protein simultaneously on your
tissue
again in-house acid services are also
available for this update
if you would like our expert scientists
to perform the assays for you with fast
results
with that i would like to thank everyone
for attending today's webinar
for further details of acd's newest
microarray scope update
please feel free to visit our website or
contact your local account manager
to learn more you can also contact our
technical support team
for any questions you may have regarding
the new essay
the support contact information is
listed here
so now we'll adjust some of your
questions like
thank you helly and miguel for your
informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
does the micro rna scope assay also
detect
pre-micrornas
thank you alexa so the microwaving scope
pro design targets the mature micrornas
sequence
the material transcript shares identical
sequence with a precursor transcript
so there might be a possibility that the
probe will recognize the precursors
however mature micrornas are more
abundantly expressed
whereas pre-micrornas are typically
present at
very low copy numbers so the signals
detected with the microniscope assay
would be mostly the mature transcripts
now helly our next question is do you
have a list of target probes available
to purchase
and also could you design probes for
custom sequences
yes absolutely we have a list of
micrornas
probes that have been pre-designed and
are available
for purchase immediately you may also
submit
custom sequences for probe defense
visibility through
our new probe request form on the
acdbio.com website
now how do you determine specificity of
the micro rna scope target probes
the microrna assay um leverages the core
irony
probe design strategies as well as the
background suppression system
to provide um high specificity and
additionally the target probe is
screened through the whole transcriptome
of the species samples
to avoid any cross hybridization and
lastly control samples are always
recommended to be used for further
evaluation of specificity
do we have time for just a few more
questions i do want to remind our
audience that those questions we are
unable to answer today and those that
come in during the on-demand period
will be answered by our speakers via the
email addresses that you provided at the
time of registration
so we'll move on to our next question
which is is the assay compatible
with the protein detection ihcif
yes the microgranule assay is compatible
with rna and protein detection
simultaneously so using
hc or if
now is the assay protocol different from
the rna scope assay
the microline scope acid protocol is
very similar
to the rna scrub athlete protocol for
those of you who are familiar
specifically the manual microscope
protocol has an extra fixation step
to ensure optimal detection of these
smaller rnas
whereas the leica protocol is very
similar to the rna scope
like a single flex assay that can be
completed within an
overnight run
and it looks like we have time for one
more question so can
a micro rna scope assay detect rnas that
are greater than 50 nucleotides
the micronuscope assay is specifically
designed to
detect smaller rnas that are 17 to 50
nucleotides
so for rnas that are greater than 50
nucleotides we
recommend on our users to use the base
copy
where it supports sequences from 50 to
300 nucleotides
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
we would like to once again thank helly
and miguel for their time today and
their important research
we would also like to thank labbert and
our sponsor advanced cell diagnostics a
biotechne brand
for underwriting today's educational
webcast you can view the webinar on
demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now and until next time
goodbye
you